so disney just took a look at the fact
that i was going to do
other stuff with my day today and went
nah no you're not
a frankly insane number of announcements
came out from disney's i guess it was a
shareholders meeting or did they hold it
i don't even know this there's a ton of
stuff is my point
uh this included trailers teasers now if
you want to see me actually react to
those trailers there's a video over in
the break room
of me doing that with well the marvel
stuff because most of the stuff that
they had for other things were
just minor teasers logo reveals behind
the scenes up which
like doesn't interest me as much and i
don't feel like i
have as much reaction to give about it
but i've got
i've got a list of stuff to go over and
to talk about
these these things specifically and also
some of the
bigger ideas about what some of this
might mean or whether or not i think
it's a good idea
so let's i have to break this down in a
lot of ways
let's start with marvel let's start with
the mcu now we had trailers
for falcon and the winter soldier one
division loki what if
uh in a sort of a behind-the-scenes
trailer for ms marvel but that barely
counts
uh the trailers were all solid looked
good obviously not the first one for one
division we now have a firm date for one
division
in january when it's going to be
released
they all seem pretty good again you can
go to the video i linked earlier
for reactions to those but
all of those were things we already knew
about and we already knew were happening
a couple of other bits of news in
relation to ms marvel they did confirm
that
the character of kama kamala khan
i see i'm wavering now because i went
back and forth like
is it kamala or kamala but on the teaser
thing they pronounced it kamala so i'm
sticking with that for now
um they did confirm she's going to
appear in captain marvel 2 which
makes it immensely obvious that they're
keeping her sort of
fan girl tendency towards the avengers
and captain marvel in particular
that sort of thing and like this ties
into some of the other stuff that's
going on as well they are integrating
much more
um tightly the stuff going on in disney
plus and the stuff going on in theaters
and
normally i would be either cautious or
would not take that very seriously
but things have kind of changed i'll
come back to that uh they confirmed that
black panther two will not
recast the part of t'challa they didn't
say
um how the story would move forward nor
did they say whether or not
they would acknowledge the character as
being dead but they did confirm they are
not recasting
chadwick boseman and they're also not
moving the production date so whatever
they thought to do
they think they can do it in the same
amount of time they had to do it before
um oh dr strange is going to end up
tying into both
one division and the as yet untitled
third spider-man film
so they really are um getting into the
multiverse thing which is another thing
that i've expressed a lot of caution
about before
and i'm i'm gonna be nervous about
always and forever
but i think if there was ever a time
where it was going to work
it kind of makes sense now because
having done a fairly
large more or less continuous everything
fits together
story that ultimately culminated in end
game
you're probably never gonna top that for
single coherent narrative so if you're
you were ever gonna splinter off and
start exploring alternate versions of
things and bringing in the idea of
different universes and and bringing in
that sort of thing this is a good
time to do it because it shakes up what
you're able to do without trying to
outdo what you did before in the same
kind of way
so i'm a little bit more open to the
idea than i have been
i just hope that they never use it to
you know say for instance bring back
tony
in another like i understand he could
still be alive in another dimension but
like
that just even tackling that takes the
power out of his death
um and i also hope that they they
don't start having a new dimension for
like
every single franchise like don't over
complicate it don't
dabble in the multiverse unless you have
to if you're gonna have it at all
but we'll see we'll see how that um all
ties together
there were announcements of a number of
shows all coming to disney plus
obviously there's going to be secret
invasion which is going to feature both
nick fury and telos the scroll played by
nick
mendelsohn uh sorry ben mendelsohn
um i don't know why i said that oh
because i said nick fury first that's
why
but in any case this is gonna kind of
pick up from the teaser that was at the
end
of the second spider-man movie which
kind of ties into what i was saying
before about them
interweaving these things a heck of a
lot more than they were
previously uh again i'll come back to
that as a general concept once i go over
all the
the mcu stuff but you know um taking on
that story or some version of
secretivation like even if any of these
titles
resemble titles from marvel comic lines
that have
happened before don't expect a direct
adaptation marvel has almost never done
that
um so they've also announced ironheart
which was the spin-off for the character
of riri williams who
is a black woman who develops an iron
man suit i think
in the comics under tony's tutelage now
obviously tony's gone so they'll have to
find a different way to integrate her
in now we don't have a lot of details on
this one but they have announced the
actress who has cast who is someone
named dominique thorne who is not an
actress i'm familiar with but
we do have that much going on they have
announced
armor wars starring don cheadle's war
machine
and again that is a title taken from i
think an 80s story from marvel
it strikes me as a little bit odd that
they announced both of these as separate
entities i would have thought especially
with
tony gone integrating those two stories
would have been a natural
fit but maybe they didn't want it to
feel like riri was playing second
fiddle to uh to war machine but
at the same time the character by her
nature has always kind of been uh
you know a second but not i mean i don't
want to imply that she's not important
or she's not a good character but she is
a derivative character
by her nature so i'm not sure there's a
way
around that uh if they pull the actual
armor war story any part of it it's
about the
iron man technology falling into the
wrong hands the sort of thing that tony
always dreaded
which would be a very natural pickup for
something uh like
uh war machine to go out and to deal
with and again
would it fit with introducing riri i
don't know
we'll have to see how it pans out i'll
be curious to see how they make these
two series
feel fundamentally different when
they're basically both iron man spinoffs
i don't know that that each individually
i'm like cool
but the fact that they're both happening
and they're separate things that
confuses me slightly
um there's going to be a guardians of
the galaxy uh christmas special
in 2022 ahead of the actual proper
guardians of the galaxy 3 which will be
the year after that
additionally there is going to be a
series of i am groot shorts
i didn't see that they confirmed it was
animated but that's my presumption
and they also confirmed tatiana maslany
best known for orphan black
will be playing jennifer walters aka
she-hulk
this has been rumored for a while but
was never confirmed up to this point so
we now do have that
i couldn't find anything that they
confirmed how they are going to realize
it and whether
you know whether they are going to cgi
her
as um as she hulk much like they do
with mark ruffalo oh who's also going to
appear in the series by the way
um but much like they do with ruffalo
for banner i
the only reason i've ever questioned
that is because that's gonna be
expensive
for a tv series and it would it would
potentially severely limit how often
they could show her as she-hulk so i've
always kind of wondered if they would do
something else either use perspective
tricks or just use the old idea from the
um the old 70s incredible hulk tv show
and have two different actors i doubt
that
at this point um because if you get
someone with the talent
like tatiana maslany has that would feel
like a waste if all you had
like was her dubbing over another
actress as she hulk but
that's all the details we got there for
films in the mcu i told you there was a
lot of stuff
for films in the mcu we there's gonna be
ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania so obviously they're going
to keep exploring the quantum realm
and that would not surprise me if that
ends up eventually tying into the whole
multiverse thing as well and that's also
going to introduce jonathan major's
star of lovecraft country as the villain
kang the conqueror who is
an interesting choice kang is one of
those characters who's
very complicated and convoluted but i'm
not sure is actually very
interesting which actually might make
him a good fit for a story that's
probably gonna lean a bit more
light-hearted
and silly cause as a villain kang is
kinda silly and has never really made
sense
um and pretty much everybody's coming
back they've confirmed that paul rudd is
coming back and eventually lily is
coming back and michelle pfeiffer is
coming back and michael douglas is
coming back
um so they're all coming back and they
have a title and they have a villain
cool
so overall thoughts about the mcu
there's a pretty good variety of stuff
here
and obviously a lot of the focus right
now is on
um the tv series going on disney plus
this really does show that disney has
a plan to handle the film separate from
the tv series whereas
we're watching warner brothers make its
announcements that it's basically
dumping everything at least for 2021
directly onto hbo max and we're seeing
some very bad fallout from that
whereas disney is seems to be very
careful about
keeping the film announcements as film
announcements now
that's not to say that none of those
will end up going to disney plus but i
think definitely the hope is for them
that
by the time these uh films get made that
things might have cleared up enough that
they can release them to theaters
and that means that they're making a
bunch of stuff actually tailored
to the platform of disney plus and
that's with all the series so
this feels very well thought out for as
many things as there are it does not
feel like
throwing everything out the wall and see
if it sticks
now in terms of the integrating of the
films with the series that's always
something i've been really skeptical
about before
because we learned pretty much
immediately with the first season of
agents of shield that
the connections were always going to be
really superficial and it was the same
with daredevil
there were references and tiny
acknowledgements in the series of the
movies
never the other way around a couple of
things have changed though since then
that
makes doing so at least a slightly more
viable option although i'm still not
sure it's a great idea
so part of the problem before was all
the television stuff
was under ike perlmutter who
um is a is a big wig at marvel i think
at this point is
basically really only doing uh the
actual publishing of the comics at this
point but
he and kevin feige who is in charge of
the movies of course they do not get
along
at all and feige basically wrestled
control
of marvel from perlmutter in terms of
everything that is
movies and television perlmutter used to
handle tv and that was part of why
trying to coordinate
um you know agents with agents of shield
with anything was such a pain in the
butt
and of course the stuff over on netflix
involved a complete other company that
disney did not have direct control over
as well whereas now
feige is actually able to exert direct
control
over basically everything except
spider-man
and sony seems willing enough to play
ball that he's probably got a good hand
in that as well
which means that it is now much more
viable to
coordinate things and actually integrate
things more tightly because you don't
have to worry about
things falling apart later and
especially on a binging platform like
disney plus
where you can be certain that at the
very least an entire first series of
something will be filmed and you don't
have to worry about oh we're going to
settle this stuff up but then we got
canceled or heck we got canceled halfway
through the season
no you shot the whole thing so you know
it's going to happen so you know how to
integrate it
that's all very viable my concern and
this has
always been my concern more people watch
the movie than watch the tv
shows so i still think it's a bad idea
to make enjoyment of the movies
dependent on knowing what has gone on in
the tv shows
i think if they go that far and they're
really borderlining it at this point if
wanda vision is going to somehow feed
into the doctor strange sequel which is
supposed to be a theatrical release
exactly how they do that i think is in
many ways going to be the command canary
in the coal mine and the test bubble
for are they going to be able to do this
in a way that does not require
every single person who likes the movies
to also watch the shows
because you might think oh well they'll
sell more subscriptions to disney plus
that way
and they will for some of them but i
would bet money that they will
lose more audience who go this has
gotten too complicated i'm done
then they will gain people crossing over
from the movie over to disney plus
again we'll have to see how this
actually plays out um to see
exactly how much they're integrating it
and then see whether or not my
fears are justified i have a suspicion
that
the integration is still largely going
to be in one direction
primarily the movies influencing the
shows minimal the other way around
that is still my expectation but we'll
see and that
could have been the whole video but now
we gotta talk about star wars oh my god
okay so we have a couple of
movie announcements the big one being
rogue squadron which is going to be
directed by patty jenkins who directed
the two wonder woman movies which
first off uh in terms of the timing this
probably wasn't planned but it feels
like a big
middle finger to warner brothers and all
the mess that they're dealing with right
now a
quick recap when warner brothers
announced
that they were putting their entire
slate of 2021 movies
day and date in theaters and on hbo max
at the same time
they pissed off a lot of people they
pissed off their major studio partners
such as legendary they pissed off
individual creators
like um denis villeneux who directed
dune
and christopher nolan who they've who
warner brothers says had an amazing
working relationship with
and now the director's guild of america
is holding talks with the studio
and it is distinctly possible that if
they don't reverse course or come to
some sort of agreement
that the director's guild will
bar its members from working with
warner brothers which would really screw
like that's how bad
lee the warner brothers has handled this
whole thing
but anyways um the reason i brought that
up is because patty jenkins
jumping ship from warner brothers and
wonder woman
over to disney and star wars i don't
think was planned as a reaction to
everything going on but uh the timing
definitely worked in disney's favor so
anyway rogue squadron which
i think had a lot of spin-off material i
know it mainly as a video game
but this is the kind of thing that i
would kind of like
i i this was why i was excited about the
spin
the idea of the spin-off movies um and
ended up really liking rogue one not
really liking solo because it was a bad
idea but um the idea of exploring
specific elements of star wars because
the movies they have a bit of everything
you know they have the
rocking adventure and the jedi and the
political stuff
and the large-scale battles and the
space dogfighting
you make something like rogue squadron
you can narrow it down to a narrow focus
and really drill into
some of these things with things like
the
pilots and the x-wings and things like
that and that is an idea that excites me
we'll see if it works out they don't
always um taikawa tt is still working on
a star wars film
that is confirmed that he's still doing
that no title yet no concept yet just
that he's doing it
whole bunch of series were announced
so let's go through these we have
confirmation of obi-wan kenobi
finally which has been rumored forever
and is going to see the return of both
you and mcgregor
and hayden christensen as darth vader
and is going to be set between episodes
three and
four which is more or less what we all
suspected although i don't
know how many people called that darth
vader would actually show up and it
seems like the main thrust is going to
be like jedi hunters you know hunting
down the stragglers that weren't caught
up in
orders uh order six six
was it um but that's that's a
pretty bog standard plot um presumably
it'll be set mostly on tatooine which
if that is the case is going to make it
interesting to see how they
differentiate it from the mandalorian
which granted
wasn't set exclusively on tatooine but
has leaned very heavily into the vibe
that's that desert settings give it so
i'll kind of be curious to see what they
do
there um there's going to be a spin-off
for ahsoka
um coming off of the mandalorian wilstar
um rosario dawson no surprise i think
pretty much everybody expected that uh
as soon as
it was announced that she was going to
play the character at all so that's not
particularly
surprising that's a very natural
extension of what they were going to do
rangers of the new republic which i
don't even know
uh apparently jean favreau is behind
this one and it's set in the same
timeline as the mandalorian
with the mandalorian appearing to have
gone down a lot better with the core fan
base than
say the last jedi or certainly rise of
skywalker did
they seem to really be leaning hard on
the mandalorian settings and everything
that went on there which
makes sense but feels very reactive
which makes me nervous i'll kind of come
back to my overall
thoughts later um confirmation about
andor which is going to star diego
luna's character from rogue one we
already knew that
uh was in the planning so that's moving
forward awesome
and i'm doubt for that again a different
element of star wars than we're used to
seeing and
you know we've seen the noble soldiers
and the pilots and the jedi we haven't
really seen
the spies the ones who have to fight
dirty for the rebellion because they
must exist otherwise the rebellion would
have been crushed a long time ago so
drilling into somebody like um
like andor is i think a really solid
idea
so i'm down for that okay there's gonna
be something called
acolyte which is coming from leslie
headland
who made russian doll for netflix which
i haven't seen but i've heard pretty
good things about
and that is apparently going to be set
in the high republic
era of star wars not that it actually
matters all that much
because the technology and general feel
of star wars doesn't
change almost no matter when you set it
old republic high republic new republic
the empire
like the only thing that seems to change
is the political situation the
technology never changes and the
general feel of the world doesn't alter
significantly so
i don't know it's part of why i i never
really got into
the the whole expanded universe you know
i'd pick up something that's like
set a thousand years before star wars
and open it up and there's
laser guns and spaceships and
lightsabers i'm like so there's
literally nothing changed in a thousand
years okay anyway my hang up
um i don't really know what to make of
that though i i need to see a
teaser or trailer or more of a concept
than what we've got
um bad batch which is a spin-off from
the clone wars
series which i still haven't watched
haven't had the time i barely have the
time to record this
um so uh presumably that
makes sense i i don't know i'm
i don't know enough about star wars to
know how the these characters
um sort of resonated and fit into
everything but hey
good for them uh something called star
wars visions which is going to be a
series of animated shorts and i'm
already questioning that title because
the fact that you are releasing a show
called one division
and also star wars visions i'm like i
somebody in marketing should have gone
uh okay somebody needs to change their
title because it actually did confuse me
maybe i'm just dumb but um i mean
animated star wars shorts is
fine that okay
um and there were a few other lucasfilm
projects they teased a new indiana jones
still with harrison ford which
i don't know if i can get excited about
and not just because of crystal skull
but just because look i like harrison
ford and he's still got it i do
genuinely think that
when i see him and stuff even now but
like
can the torch has to get past at some
point doesn't it
apparently he's going to be directed by
james mangold who's a very solid
director and a good pick if spielberg's
not going to do it so
i mean that's something they also teased
willow which is going to be a follow-up
series to the movie
being on disney plus i am bizarrely
excited about this
willow i think is a really
under-appreciated movie and if you're
not
from my generation you probably don't
really know much about it at all but
i really enjoy it i think it's a cool
world and it is
a world that already has a lot of um
follow-up material to draw from because
there was i think a trilogy of novels um
written by chris claremont based off
george lucas's ideas for what would have
been sequels now that's not to say that
the willow
series has to be a direct adaptation of
those it absolutely doesn't have to but
there is existing material for it to
draw ideas from
and forge its own path which to me puts
it on solid ground to move forward
and it it's also the kind of thing that
feels like more of a passion project
because willow was never big enough for
this to feel like a cash in
you know what i mean and finally from
lucasfilm something called the children
of blood and bone which is based off a
novel by
i'm probably going to butcher this i
apologize tommy adeyemi
uh which the i i know nothing about this
book
um but it seems like an interesting idea
dealing with
a young african girl trying to reconnect
with
if i understood it properly sort of
ancestral magics
it's a it's a neat idea but again i
really know nothing about it
so talking about the overall plan for
star wars
comparing it to marvel as i at the word
i already used it is
this feels much more reactionary whereas
marvel's it feels like this was more or
less always the plan i mean maybe
there's a few more disney plus
series now than they would have been
thinking initially because
you know pandemic but star wars really
does
feel purely reactionary purely okay
things haven't been going quite right
what can we do that people will like
better and it inherently makes me
more nervous about it because when you
do something
uh as a reaction to what's going on i'm
not going to say that can never work out
but
you're you're trying to catch up to what
people want as opposed to forging your
own path and seeing if people come with
you
so as far as the specific things go
i i'm i'm more nervous about this many
shows set in star wars than i am about
how many marvel shows there are because
the marvel shows can have
very distinctly different feels i mean
just look at the trailer for loki and
then
a winter soldier falcon and winter
soldier for a comparison
those feel like completely different
things in terms of
tone in terms of setting in terms of
just
everything visual presentation the works
star wars has generally gone for a lot
more visual consistency
and because they have yet to really
properly branch out and look
at the world outside of the conflicts
between
either the sith and the jedi or the
rebellion and the empire or the first
order and the
um uh they weren't even the rebellion
anymore
i don't know whatever they called the
rebellion that time
i you can see the new trilogy has faded
from my from my head
but though then that conflict is
functionally identical to
empire versus rebels it there isn't
as much variety and i i'm
much more worried about oversaturation
of star wars than i am of over
saturation of marvel because there's a
lot more opportunity to do wildly
different things with marvel properties
and they haven't really found a way to
do that with star wars it all still has
to quote-unquote
feel like star wars about the farthest
they've gone afield to something like
the mandalorian which has a more
a smaller scale and you know a bit more
of sort of the
the western lone wolf kind of thing
going for it but
the overall world is still very much
star wars
it they have not found a way to grow and
expand
things in the same way and that makes me
nervous
as far as the specific things i mean
honestly um
there isn't really enough for me to get
that excited yet about any of it because
we've
got no trailers and we don't have a lot
to to go off of
i mean obi-wan kenobi's probably the one
that i'm the closest to excited about
um just because i like ewan mcgregor on
the role and i'm down for more of it
and that's kind of it though i think it
says a lot about the state of where i am
in terms of star wars overall while i
while i enjoyed the first season of the
mandalorian i haven't
watched season two i don't know when i
will
but my overall feeling towards star wars
is like
okay i
you know i i was i was kind of
kind to the uh rise of skywalker when it
came out
but it definitely didn't leave me
wanting more
of star wars afterwards and that's kind
of where i am right now
i'm i'm feeling like i might be full so
i don't know if my
feeling there is reflective of anybody
else's but that's just me there was also
a whole bunch of other stuff announced
for other disney properties and i'm not
going to go through all of these but i
am going to highlight the ones that i
found most interesting or at least have
something to say about
so reya and the last dragon that is
going to hit theaters and streaming at
the same time day and date
theatrical and streaming now
as i mentioned warner brothers doing the
same thing in 2021
has gotten them into a lot of hot water
there's a big key well there's a couple
of big key differences here with what
disney's doing with this film
the first is that they don't have to
worry about pissing off a lower studio
because it's their film
they made it they're releasing it so
they don't have to worry about bungling
uh relations with people outside of the
studio
the way that warner brothers has managed
to do and the other thing is
this film is scheduled to release in
march which means it's early enough in
the year
that it we are probably still going to
be dealing with a pandemic is that at
that point look i know there's a
there's a vaccine and and all that but
the roll
out for that and the amount of time it's
going to take
to truly get as many people as need to
be
vaccinated properly and for things to
even begin to go back to what they were
it's not going to be by march
absolutely no way and i think disney
knows that but
unlike warner brothers who just rode off
all of 2021
in an effort to try and boost hbo max
because they're
terrified of their new corporate
overlords at at t
but with disney i suspect they're gonna
do
a rolling thing with that and they
announced it for march because
yeah things will probably still not be
great in terms of theatrical film
being released in march and i expect
depending on how things clear up after
that they may or may not announce
later films in the year as we get into
may june
july you know and then the latter half
of the year
they may continue to announce day and
date as we
go depending on how circumstances are
um and that's and that's just a much
smarter approach
uh again certainly in terms of not just
throwing your whole slate under the bus
uh what else we got oh there's gonna be
a there's gonna be a number of spin-off
series
um from various disney and pixar
and etc properties there's going to be a
baymax series
there's going to be a zootopia series
there's going to be a series for
tiana from princess and the frog there's
going to be a cars spin-off series a
spin-off series about doug
the dog from up
i just part of what frustrates me here
is particularly the baymax one
because i look i haven't actually liked
really i don't think any of the disney
or pixar
sequels all that much i think the one i
disliked to the least was frozen too
i really didn't like ralph breaks the
internet and i didn't get much out of
incredibles 2 but i have always wanted a
proper sequel to big hero 6
not a spin-off series which has already
had and now and now
a series about being like just give me a
proper sequel so like i'm
a little spiteful about that in and of
itself
as far as the others go zootopia
honestly makes sense because they
created this whole
this whole world this whole city there's
a lot of crevices of it to explore you
don't even have to stick
strictly to the police work of judy and
nick but even if you did you can weave
them in and out of a lot of different
stories so that actually makes sense uh
as a series i think
tiana i don't know i kind of want to
hear what the premise is i don't know
what you'll do with that
but then again i also heard pretty good
things about the tangled series and i
wouldn't have known what you would do
with that either so
hey what do i know i mean the ones
spinning out from cars and and uh
from up i mean like i never was
i never really liked cars but it's i
know it's always been a big money maker
for them so i guess that's not that
surprising but what about doug
is weird like if that was announced as
another sort of series of shorts like i
am groot
i'd get it but like proper series you
sure about that
um they also announced a number of
upcoming pixar films
um most of them you know new stuff that
we don't know a lot about yet
um there's one called red panda which is
fingers crossed their first film
directed by a woman that was supposed to
be brave but there were not
enough clashes with that director that
she did not see that film through to the
end
so we'll see if that actually happens
this time there's another one that i
can't even remember now i didn't write
it down and then there's
light year which is an origin story
about buzz lightyear with chris evans
voicing buzz lightyear so i guess
the premise is that
what if buzz was like real
what would his story have been um
and i i guess that's part of justifying
not casting
tim allen because he would be the voice
of the toy
of buzz as opposed to the voice of the
real buzz
i guess it's i i need to see like a
proper trailer not just a teaser on this
because this is a concept that's making
me go
you're just trying to ring out nostalgia
dollars aren't you
which i think is worth mentioning about
this whole
slate of stuff i kind of have mixed
feelings about this because on the one
hand
it feels like a lot and it is a lot but
as most of it's going to disney plus
this is not dissimilar from a tv network
announcing its slate of upcoming shows
in a new season
it's kind of along the same line so yeah
there's a lot of stuff but at the same
time
much more so than you would get from say
a network tv show
almost all of it
is spin-off or adaptation or
in some way tied to existing property
there isn't
a lot of original content on display
which in terms of like getting everybody
on board with your service
is probably not what you need anyways
but it does make me nervous
how few properly i mean like even some
of the stuff that i didn't write down
like there's gonna be a follow-up to the
mighty
ducks for crying out loud i'm
as much as i enjoy a lot of this
material
the aversion to new ideas
is starting to worry me about the
closest we're getting to new ideas
honestly is the mcu stuff because
they are introducing a fair number of
new characters including a bunch that
you know didn't really show up in the
announcements because
there wasn't new stuff to talk about
with them with things like moon night
and
and things like that but even those are
still
as i said getting more integrated and
more tied into the other mcu stuff so
even that
even if it's introducing whole new
characters
like she-hulk like kamala khan
it still feels derivative and still
feels like a spin-off
a bit less so than stuff like lightning
mcqueen and mater getting a series but
still it worries me a little bit
but then again this is kind of the state
of the industry
they want guaranteed success and
banking on an existing name tying it to
something that you already know people
like
that's risk avoidance that's just what
it is from a corporate
perspective so it is what it is i i feel
like
seeing the full list of everything just
put that situation into much starker
perspective than i think i've had
in a little while but oh
there was one other thing that i'm like
ooh so
they've put noah holly who is the
creator behind
fargo and legion on
a uh alien series
for fx i
am always curious to see what noah holly
does so
i'm on board for that so i think
that that about wraps it up for me
overall i think
certainly there's for the most part this
makes a heck of a lot more sense than
certainly anything warner brothers has
been saying lately um i feel like the
mcu
is the most um carefully assembled
lineup of projects
star wars i need to see more about these
things before i can really decide
whether or not i'm excited about any of
them
and then most of the rest of the stuff i
don't have a strong opinion on because
it's pretty much all aimed at kids and
most of it doesn't really appeal to me
but again
worries me how much of it is derivative
works
but there we go i know that wasn't
everything but that's as much as i'm
prepared to talk about
what do you think about any or all of
what i've just gone through
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it like share subscribe
i have a patreon which is what pays my
bills and allows this entire thing to
keep
going any amount you are able to give
helps there are perks at every support
level but you also don't have to
end of the day you're the council i'm
just running the meetings and until next
time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
now
[Music]